Pete sam'l from Yahoo joining us now to
talk little hoops hey Pete thanks for
coming on with us man I much appreciate
it
hey guys what's going on another
Syracuse guys we look at familes resume
here as Brockman is nodding his head in
approval Pete I my agents from Syracuse
I did a football game for the AAF over
the weekend my sideline reporter was
from Syracuse my producer was from
Syracuse I mean what's what's in the
water up there it's unbelievable I can't
get away from you guys yeah it's kind of
like a kind of like a mafia yeah we're
just sort of slowly surround and
suffocate they're everywhere
you guys are everywhere there's probably
some guys from that selection committee
from Syracuse as well this might be the
best job they've ever done all the top
12 seeds move on for the first time in a
decade is that good or bad for the
tournament well I mean look it is it
good the actual tournament it's great
they're gonna get monster ratings and
great games but I think it's terrible
for the tournament I just say there's
you know when or again with its billion
dollar you know Nike deal that's an
exaggeration but you know still nice
given them hundreds of millions of
dollars when they're your clucky
double-digit seed that's all you need to
know about you know sort of where this
is but there's nobody yeah there's no
Duluth there's just you know it's like
there's a bunch of like apple verse
Microsoft matchups in the next round and
it's it's I mean the magic of March is
you know I think you guys are saying
sister Jean and towards me sin and BCU
and Butler and there's just no magic
just really good games let's look back
before we look forward for a moment for
me I think the most memorable moment of
the the first week of the tournament was
was jammer and I'm not hearing very well
yeah let me let me let me talk a little
bit louder you hear me okay Pete yeah I
got you a little bit now it's just it's
really faint I apologize hey no worries
John Marant for me the most memorable
thing about the first weekend outside of
maybe the the Duke UCF game was there
one thing in particular or to the
maybe stood out to you the most from the
first week yeah I was in Hartford
covering for Yahoo that the John Moran
show and it was fantastic I mean that
game against Marquette was one of the
best individual performances I've ever
seen on a basketball court he was just
so dominant and just did so many things
that's such a high level that I could
not have been more impressed with with
the way he played he passes like Ben
Simmons he's got a Russell Westbrook
first step at the ball really really
well even in that Florida State game
when that team was clearly overwhelmed
yet this was you know the first weekend
will be remembered for for that John
Moran moment and that was really other
than our friends the Anteaters the only
you know significant upset but let's
face it Murray was only a three point
underdog yeah the difference between the
sort of mid-major flotsam and jetsam I'm
sorry hi major flotsam and jetsam sludge
that it sort of is just you know eats
its way into the tournament year after
year the st. John's the Arizona States
those those types of teams even like
Mike Ole Miss like you know they're at
90 but they were you know they just got
blasted on you know the differencing
them and the really high really high
high end mid majors a team like Murray
but you look at places like Furman and
Greensboro and other things there's
really not that much difference it's
between you know between those between
those two caliber programs and you know
Murray was Murray was a blast to watch
against against Marquette and it was
because of job who is the easiest path
among the top seeds would you say that's
Virginia just because organs next up in
the bracket yeah I mean look Oregon was
this high in the top 15 this year so and
then they had a bunch of injuries and
had to sort of reinvent themselves every
ball ball got hurt Kenny Wooten brokest
knows that they just you know organs are
really good basketball team so you know
they they're probably you know III took
them to get this far I just thought they
were they were pretty good I actually
picked them to be Virginia so I don't
know virginia's biggest biggest demon is
gonna be virginia right like you know
how do they handle the stage they
haven't handled it well at not only in
against UMBC last year but at different
points in the tournament they've not
only lost but they've lost authoritative
lee at times and their offense is just
ground to a halt
so you know maybe that maybe that
slowstar against gardner-webb help them
exercise some of those demons but it's
hard to say anyone has really you know
there's there's statistically there
really isn't one so it's you know I
think we're really due to have a
historic weekend of great games and work
quite frankly just statistically reduce
some great games because there weren't
that many that's opening week no that's
a great point and you know talking
earlier about John Moran if he was the
most impressive player that you saw in
the tournament who's been the most
impressive team did I did I see
correctly that Gonzaga hasn't lost in a
hundred days well no that's wrong
because they lost the st. Mary's st.
Mary's no I mean I think they lost once
in a hundred they haven't lost a ton
would they be the most impressive team
so far no yeah I mean it was really good
and I honestly just because of tip times
and cover my own games didn't see much
of them and the them in the first round
I'll say this I took Carolina to win and
nothing that I saw is really backed
backed me off that they just obliterated
that zone which they they've done I
think they beat Syracuse aged three
times it wasn't a surprise that they
were ready to they were ready to handle
that to handle that zone yeah I really
I'm really still bullish on Carolina and
I think they're the best overall team
Duke obviously as the best high-end
talent is not only was I on but you know
his crew with reddish and Barrett and
Jones but at the end of it Duke is very
thin and you need to win tournament
games in different ways they're not a
good three-point shooting team they're
not a good free-throw shooting team
there are vulnerabilities that you know
make make a Duke a Duke loss from this
point on with coffeeshop
I think everybody has some
vulnerabilities it's just who has the
fewest let me ask you about my Tennessee
Volunteers for a minute in the sweet 16
for the first time since 2014 they held
that number one ranking for around three
weeks during the regular season I've
seen a lot of people who have picked
Tennessee to pick somebody other than
Duke to win the tournament a lot of
great senior leaders I obviously I'm
biased but I love the way that this team
plays because I believe that they are
a true team and during the regular
season I thought that they had a shot to
win it all certainly I don't think
anybody as you mentioned has you know
three top five picks like Duke does but
you know there's some NBA players on
this roster and there's some guys who
can win you ball games more than one
more than just two guys there's probably
three guys that you can count on in
crunch time here
look I pick Tennessee to make fun for I
think they are they are very good it'll
be it'll be interesting as they go on
because Tennessee's weaknesses they
don't have the high high highs and a
linear eventually going to have to face
high high high in town so you know the
narrative will be like teamers talents
that kind of thing is there an excellent
college basketball team that requires
it's done a fantastic job Rick Barnes
historically is not a great NCAA
tournament coach he's old for five and
eight nine games which is just kind of
amazing if he's didn't think about it
and you know some of those demons
obviously almost comprehends the I wa
the other day so it'll be interesting is
it's an interesting maritime in
Tennessee they've clearly over achieved
for who they are nobody thought they'd
be this good right and but if you lose
early in the tournament after
overachieving people think you under a
tea for the season it's a funny it's a
funny tension in line there that that
Barnes is straddling I give him all
kinds of credit he's know he's done a
wonderful job and it'll be fascinating
to see as the matchups become
heavyweight matchup how Tennessee
matches up talking about overachieving
they're the Yale over LSU pick in the
first round was very popular in a lot of
brackets and then LSU beats a Maryland
team that was at times very good
throughout the course of the season
their head coach has been suspended
they're surprised at all I mean I know
they're a three seed and they have a
tough matchup against Michigan State to
see LSU who might many have said in
terms of athleticism and talent might be
the second best team in the tournament
yeah I think they could be the most
athletic team in the table em Florida
State just you know when you go one two
one two nine they're huge they're
massive they're they're athletic they
can physically match up with any with
any team in the country to be
interesting to see Tony Benford kind of
wasted the game away against Florida and
SEC Tournament got a really bad
technical that let
Sixpoint possession that that caused
huge swing and in that game and
obviously the caliber of teams LSU is
going to be facing and cover of coaches
quite frankly it could be Tom Izzo and
Coach K you'd have to think there's a
there's a there's a mismatch there you
know that's that's the team that NCAA's
got to be rooting hardest against
because when your coach suspended on you
know after a report that he's been on a
wiretap talking about an offer to a
player it's not exactly a shining moment
that I think Mark Emmert and crew at
want matchup you're most looking forward
to in the Sweet sixteen is it a Duke
Virginia Tech and LSU Michigan State
maybe in North Carolina Auburn so I'm
gonna be in DC so I'm really looking
forward to do coaching attackers a heck
of a game in Blacksburg Duke lost
without Zion there you know Virginia
Tech is a very big old veteran well
coached team you know the Hokies are
gonna show out in DC that's this huge
huge alumni base there so and anytime
Zion is an arena like it's electric so I
would probably say that game is the is
the one I'm looking forward to the most
quickly before we let you go no Zion in
that game but people don't talk that
much about it our friend Seth Davis said
it last night
Justin Robinson the starting point guard
at the time for Virginia Tech not didn't
play in that game either yes and Justin
Robinson is one of the ten best players
and ACC's is it in his return is really
you know it really gives a Virginia Tech
a legitimate shot to go the final four
Wow
Hokies in the Final Four that would be a
lot of happy fans there you're right a
big hockey fan base there in Washington
DC Pete Hamill from Yahoo formerly of
Sports Illustrated and the New York
Times hey Pete enjoy the run my friend I
think it is the best sporting event of
the year to cover man I am very jealous
that you're gonna be in DC getting a
chance to watch these games thanks so
much appreciate them the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience